police and Lahore surrounded the
residents of former prime minister Imran
Khan they promised to arrest him by the
end of the day speaking to his
supporters Khan struck a defiant tone
[Music]
I'm fighting your fight I have struggled
all my life and will continue to fight
but if they put me behind bars or kill
me then you have to prove that without
me this nation will struggle for Freedom
there were confrontations between Khan
supporters and the police Khan was
ousted from Power last year but he
remains a popular figure
police want to detain him for failing to
comply with an order to appear in court
to face dozens of charges speaking
exclusively to Al Jazeera he denied any
wrongdoing this is absolutely a
fabricated uh uh allegation it's not
even a there's nothing it's not even
contested by us it's just a judge an
allegation made by the police by this
government now there are 80 cases
against me and let's just to let you
know in the last few months every other
day there's a fresh case so if there's a
case of murder there's a case of
sedition there's a case of blasphemy
there's a case of terrorism so the every
other day there's a case
but some legal experts say Khan's
refusal to appear in court is a serious
matter then the lawyers appeared on
Monday in The Honorable High Court the
law the lawyer of Imran Khan he just
said that Imran Khan cannot can come to
the court due to some security reasons
then the honorable High Court give
directions to the police to the IG that
we want Imran Khan till 18th of March in
this court because it's a non-bailable
warrant and a charge has to be framed
while charging a frame the accused
should be in the court
elections are set to take place later
this year Khan's rallies have been
banned in recent days and supporters say
this is just another attempt to prevent
him campaigning to help his party Vinton
Monahan Al Jazeera
well Kamal Haider has more on this now
from Islamabad
well it appears that the arrest will
take place sometime within the next few
hours those are the reports that we are
getting is a 10 standoff still continues
the police is lobbying tear gas shells
into Imran Khan's Residence at Damon
Park where hundreds of his supporters
have gathered and are pushing the police
back the government has also instructed
the paramilitary forces to also beef up
the police and the apprehension is that
Imran Khan is likely to be arrested
sometime tonight he's already announced
an emergency Committee of his leaders
these are six leaders of his party who
in the case of his arrest will be making
key decisions but in the meantime people
have come out in other cities as well in
other provinces there's been protests
many arrests have been made and
according to the latest information that
we are getting prisoner Vans have been
brought to Zaman park that is Imran
Khan's residence there is anticipation
that many of his supporters will be
arrested as the police moves in and
attempts to arrest him